while president biden has focused on
global issues this week there's another
battle that could directly affect the
church going president
the debate centers around whether roman
catholic politicians who also support
abortion rights should be allowed to
receive communion
a decision would not only affect
president biden others like
nancy pelosi our house speaker is also
catholic ed o'keefe reports on this
complicated
and sensitive debate
[Music]
weather in washington his home state of
delaware or even in
england this past weekend one thing is
constant
president biden heads to catholic mass
mr president how's that church
but the president's faith is under a new
spotlight this week as the nation's more
than 200 catholic bishops gather
virtually
among the topics to be discussed whether
high-profile catholic politicians
should be denied communion if they
support abortion rights
cbs news papal and vatican contributor
monsignor anthony figuero
says the catholic church's opposition to
abortion is clear
and even pope francis you know he has
called it
an abomination
the bishop's focus will be on whether to
draft an official document clarifying
the church's position on receiving the
sacrament of communion
sometimes the church has really failed
on making the church's teaching
known and understood
[Music]
catholic church policy says that any
parishioner in good standing can receive
communion at mass
but bishops are divided over whether a
vocal political supporter of abortion
rights
qualifies the president has said he's
personally opposed to abortion
but in 2019 dropped his long-standing
opposition to federal funding for
abortion procedures
but circumstances have changed the
decision to give communion is still up
to each of the country's more than 200
diocesan bishops
washington's cardinal wilton gregory
says he plans to give communion to the
president
i'm most grateful to our holy father
pope francis for his trust
that he's placed in me but the incoming
bishop of wilmington delaware
the president's home diocese hasn't said
what he would do
san francisco's archbishop salvador
corder leone
one of the most vocal critics of
politicians who support abortion rights
will be part of this week's discussions
but he says they're not only about
abortion
helping people return to uh the holy
eucharist
understanding what it is and
appreciating the gift and that they're
living their life
in a way that is coherent with what it
means to receive holy communion
cordeliani says he wouldn't give
president biden communion in part
because the president's publicly at odds
with an issue the church considers
very important we praise where we can
but we need to correct where we need to
correct but others disagree
san diego bishop robert mcelroy wrote
last month that weaponizing the
eucharist
will bring the terrible partisan
divisions that have plagued our nation
into the very act of worship
polls show church membership has
steadily declined over the years
and catholic university's kurt martins
says public debate over mr biden's faith
could be harmful if you single out a
president or any catholic politician
you're blowing up bridges a dialogue
is much better than
the finger lifted trying to
say from the pulpit here is what you're
going to do
asked for comment about the implications
of this meeting on the president the
white house said simply quote
the president is a strong person of
faith final resolution on this likely
won't come until november at the
earliest when the bishops are scheduled
to meet again
and the vatican is strongly urging
american catholic bishops
not to take up this issue today arguing
that it would politicize the eucharist
tony very interesting ed thank you very
much